prime minister you're announcing the ban
on Russian Diamond Imports and other
sanctions on additional for G7
individuals or companies linked to Putin
do you expect other G cup seven
countries to follow you this weekend
what's your message to Peter Well I
think the most important thing we can do
right now for Global Peace and Security
is to support Ukraine and it's its
struggle against Russia but also to
ensure that Russia pays a price for its
illegal and unprovoked active aggression
that's why we've announced new sanctions
today we are talking with our Allied
countries our partner countries and I do
expect others to follow as they have
done throughout the last year of this
where we have often taken the lead
whether it's providing resources to
Ukraine or sanctions and we've seen
other countries partner with us because
ultimately sanctions are more effective
when they're done in a coordinated
fashion and I hope that's what we'll see
here as well okay so sanctions for
Russia do you expect this war to end
next year what's your message to Putin
my message to Putin is straightforward
in when not going away
Russia has conducted an illegal
unprovoked act of aggression by invading
Ukraine and Russia needs to know that we
in other countries remain steadfast in
our resolve to support Ukraine not just
in the here and now with the resources
it needs to defend itself but for the
long term as well and one of the topics
of conversation I'll be having and have
been having with my fellow leaders is
about the longer term security
agreements that we put in place for
Ukraine to deter future Russian
aggression and make them realize that
they should just withdraw their forces
okay prime minister why is bringing down
overall net migration numbers so
important to you because it's something
that we said we would do in our
Manifesto I know it's important to the
country but I also know that tackling
illegal migration is the country's
priority and that's why one of my five
priorities is to stop the boats part of
our ability to do that is cooperating
with other countries which is why I was
pleased this week that we've opened up
negotiations with the EU for our border
agencies to cooperate more closely and
that practical cooperation will help us
break the criminal gangs tackle illegal
migration and to help stop the boats and
prime minister's overall net migration
numbers going up or down
well we'll see when the latest numbers
are reported but my my clear goal is to
reduce the levels of legal net migration
whilst at the same time focusing
relentlessly on stopping illegal
migration and that's why one of my five
priorities is to stop the boats and what
were migration net migration numbers
last year as I said the numbers last
year I mean you'll have them on top of
your head we're about to get new ones
and we know that numbers are too high
and I want to bring them down I've been
very clear that my goal is to bring
those numbers let's unpack it a bit
because back in 2019 the government
promised to cut like my net migration at
the time it was 226 000 it's gone up it
was 504 000 last year will it go down
next year oh well just just on the
numbers last year if you actually look
at that release that was put out it's
very clear that there are a set of
factors which led to those numbers
including for example Ukrainian refugees
which are included in those numbers so I
think we need to treat a little so high
numbers of foreign workers and student
visas as well of unique circumstances
relating to our Refugee programs for
bringing Ukrainian okay refugees look
I'm not I'm not going to preempt what
the future numbers are but what I can
tell you is I want to bring the numbers
of legal net migration down that's
something that we said we would do and
we remain committed to doing that we're
reforming our welfare system to ensure
that we can move people off welfare and
into work I think everyone would agree
that it's far better for our economy and
far better for people if we can do that
and at the same time as I said crucially
we must tackle illegal migration and
that's why probably
I haven't got long um the forecast say
it will continue to climb to between 650
000 and nearly a million if it's
anywhere near those numbers will you
have failed as a government again Beth
you're speculating on what may or may
not be what I can tell you is I am
committed to bringing the levels of
legal migration down we're very clear
about that there's a range of options
we're considering and at the same time I
think people know that I'm relentlessly
focusing on stopping the boats because
the levels of illegal migration are too
high okay escalated massively in the
last week I promised what I'm hearing is
in 2019 you said you would bring them
down below uh 226
000 the tall the conservative government
last year they were five thousand five
hundred and four thousand next to their
predict this the year to June 2023 their
June 2022 so they predicted to go up to
1 million and you're not acknowledging
that at all is a problem or saying that
you might have failed as a government by
failing to live up to that commitment
for the British people what I'm not
acknowledging is the specific figures
because we don't know them yet and it
wouldn't be right to speak
as we've already said is that the levels
of legal migration we want to bring down
I'm very clear about that I mean I'm
absolutely committed to doing that
there's a range of options that we're
looking at I do think the numbers last
year were impacted by the fact that we
welcomed Ukrainian refugees to the UK
which is something I think collectively
let me put it this way then let's try
and get a commitment out of you do you
commit to bringing them back down below
400 504 000 by the next general election
as I said I'm committed to Bringing Down
the levels of but yeah
inherited and I'm relentlessly focused
on stopping the boats that's one of my
five priorities and we're doing
absolutely everything we can to do that
too do you accept that by the next
election you might not be able to bring
them down below half a million again I'm
focused on bringing down the levels of
legal migration but I am also completely
focused as one of my priorities of
stopping the boat and I think that is
the country's priority when it comes to
migration it's tackling illegal
migration it's stopping the boat that's
why we're passing New York and
Parliament cooperating and returning
over a thousand I think legal migrants I
think what viewers might see is that in
2019 though 224 000 they're now half a
million in the year to June 2021 and
there probably could go up to nearly a
million next week but
um and you can't give me a figure as to
what you'll commit to but anyway let's
move on
want to bring those levels down and I
think people know that I'm working night
and day to tackle illegal migration one
of my five priorities is to stop the
boats I think people know that and
that's why we're passing new laws I
think most people will agree that that's
the right priority all right for us
prime minister you're one of my success
stories you were head boy at school you
had a career in finance that made you
very wealthy now you're prime minister
how do you feel when you lose
sorry how do you feel when you lose how
do you mean that
well you're a winner in life how do you
feel when you don't win well look my my
focus in this job is to deliver for the
country I've set out five very clear
priorities to hard inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
stop the votes all I'm doing every day
is focus on delivering for people
against those five priorities I firmly
believe that that's what the country
wants me to do that's what the
government is committed to doing and
we're working night and day to make sure
that that happens and you you lost to
Liz truss last year
um did that hurt more or less than
losing over a thousand Council seats at
your first test at the ballot it's
always disappointing to lose a
hard-working counselors but the message
I've taken as a country wants me to
redouble our efforts and deliver for
them as I said the five priorities have
set out I believe are the right ones to
halve inflation grow the economy reduce
debt cut waiting list and stop the vote
did you that that's what the country
wants us to focus on that's what I am
focusing on day and night and I will
keep at it that that morning were you
quite dotted as I said it was just
pointing to lose hard-working
conservative counselors many of them are
friends and colleagues as well but I'm
going to work very hard to deliver for
the country and I'll go in the five
priorities I've set out I believe are
the right ones those are the country's
priorities to have inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
stop the votes day and night that's what
I'm focused on that's what the
government's focused on and you know
whilst things are tough I'm confident
that things will improve and people will
be able to see that we are delivering
for them improving their lives I'm
nearly out of time but just on that
you've been saying things are
Improvement for households in the UK but
do you acknowledge many people are
having a really tough time but I always
acknowledge that I always I literally
just said it as well of course it's
tough time at the moment the number one
challenge that families are facing is
with the cost of living that's why my
first priority is to halve inflation
it's why we tax the windfall profits of
energy companies last year and use that
money to pay around half of a typical
household's energy bill that support is
worth 1500 pounds now we did that
because we know things are difficult and
we will keep helping people with the
cost of living and what's your message
to the father on Sky News this week you
had to steal baby formula milk because
he couldn't afford to feed his child
yeah I'm very sorry to hear that I know
things are difficult what I would say to
families in that situation is please go
and talk to your local Council the
government has made available a billion
pounds to local Council so something
called a household support fund it is
there that money is there to support
families who are in particularly
difficult circumstances who for whatever
reason all the other support we've put
in place isn't sufficient or isn't
getting to them and there is lots of
support in place for vulnerable families
and we haven't got time to go over all
the different things now but that money
is there with your local Council please
go and talk to them awesome about the
household support fund the government
has given councils a billion pounds to
help families who are vulnerable and
need that extra help and in his shoes
would you have done the same
to comment on the particular
circumstances of many families I'll tell
you what I'm doing in this job is making
sure that we've provided extra Financial
Resources to councils so that they can
help families who are in difficult
situation with a little bit of extra
help with Essentials like that I would
urge them to go and talk to their
Council because that support is there
okay prime minister thank you so much
thank you very much